[Music]
what up what up what up what up what up
how you livin how you doing is the LEF
koe min and we are back from July 4th
weekend Ingeborg how was it it was
delightful was it time with the baby
time with the family a lot of grilling
which we're gonna talk about in a little
bit yeah just just some some long days
where you're just focusing on family it
was really nice hot dogs steaks I said a
steak and cheese I don't know if there's
a holiday other than maybe Thanksgiving
where I load up the plate to a point
where I'm not gonna eat all this food
you know what I like but I want to try
every I don't load up the plate I do the
the seven hours of just constantly
eating a little bit the nosh the nosh
the tour of the kitchen you show up it
Oh a piece of American cheese sure Oh
I'll pull apart cinnamon bread sure I'm
more of the rice no sense I just always
have a paper plate in my hand and I'm
like I'm gonna grab a burger okay I'm
gonna go away I'm gonna do something
with my cousin then I'm gonna go here
and I'm gonna grab a hot dog that I'm
gonna go away it's like I never load up
the plate and sit down I enjoy making
drinks for cousins that I've never been
able to make drinks before mmm that's
what I enjoy giving you specialty no
it's just they're like they're like I'm
not my first time being 21 and I'm like
all right got you man did I tell you I
was I drink white wine on ice though in
the summer so I'm not really that no no
judgments for tequila I went full omelet
chef had a party with some friends we
watched the World Cup final yes Sunday
morning and I decided to become the
omelet chef because it was being started
11:00 a.m. I just decided to set up a
station that happened like a dozen
omelets right in the road it was fun I
learned a lot about grilling this
weekend by the way we're gonna have
Warren sharp on in just a little bit he
breaks down he went through every single
offensive and defensive play to make his
book 2019 football preview it's
available now short football and
analysis but which teams impressed in
the most when he went back which teams
frustrating the most whose strength of
schedule one from the easiest to the
hardest I think some information that's
really gonna help you bet some over and
unders and then Barnes just he's a g-man
he
he's one of these guys in this New Age
NFL that loves to just cover the NFL and
it's what he does yeah and anytime that
I can tap into those guys brains to not
just be like I got a hunch the Eagles
are gonna be good that they can go know
like they're one of the forefront of
changing the game I'm gonna pick his
brain he's got this way of saying
extremely insightful things in a way
that makes them feel obvious yes
he says this thing we were like oh wait
oh oh my god that's that's really
insightful but it was right there in
front of you whole time yeah whole time
just did the work he did the numbers and
then after that I'm gonna get into look
man we just went through MBA free agency
and there are some numbers that happened
that were wild and I know that some of
you out there going but Adam there's
more games in the NBA there's less
players I know all of that information
but I just want to say some things to
you after the war and sharp interview to
give you some perspective of the gap
between the NFL and NBA as the NFL
approaches its collective bargaining
agreement but what I learned over the
weekend was a lot about NFL quarterbacks
with grilling right of all the lists
we've done so far I have not been this
prepared for any of them I've noticed
that about you I think you're you're
increasing your intensity
this was our searchable because what I
tell everybody is you can learn a lot by
just using Google and so when I can type
in Nick Foles cook Nick Foles grill Nick
Foles barbecue I have every story that's
ever been written where it could have
been mentioned I have watched video of
Jimmy Garoppolo making pizzas I have
gone to the depths of Andy Dalton's IG
to discover that he had a green egg
grill I have been so prepared for this
list that I think it resonated with
people we're getting to a point with
these lists we've been mentioned on
other websites before right Dan Orlovsky
went to argue with me this time David
Carr was hopping in the mentions but I
feel pretty good about it
the top five as it came out whence was
number five Keenum a surprise for many
was number four
rivers was three Stafford was two and
Brees was number one right let me give
you a quick download and then I'm gonna
let you poke some holes whence was up
there because he's getting something
that no one else is gonna provide he was
serving venison cheesesteaks in an
Instagram of a deer that he killed
earlier that week I just can't get that
from anywhere else to have it know that
is they can't
that's value add value if he's gonna
open the carson wentz restaurant and
it's only meals that he himself has shot
yes you know taking out with a bow and
arrow
that's pretty impressive that's
impressive Brees was number one because
no one had more posts about barbecue and
grilling and different recipes and all
the stuff and other teammates commenting
under his IG posts master griller like
when teammates feel the need to chime in
Stafford I read articles that he's so
proficient in the kitchen that he will
hang over his wife's shoulder while
she's cutting onions and if she's not
doing it right we'll take over he also
said that he gave grills to his
offensive line and has them over for all
holidays so that's why he went number
two keenum when I saw that he had a rib
rack on his big green egg and I thought
man backup quarterbacks are gonna go
that much further over the top to make
sure that you're feeling comfortable in
their homes that's why I got there and
Rivers was gonna be in that top five no
matter what right because every time he
makes a family meal outdoors it's
essentially as big as a neighborhood
barbecue is for most other people are
there any names in the top five or that
missed or names that you thought would
be in the top five well as you my
reasoning the the top five I feel like
your your well-reasoned here again like
me arguing with you about grill rankings
at this point is a lot like you trying
to argue with sharp about over unders
it's like he's done way more research
than you will ever but what I like is
you would come with the public
consciousness of I thought Fitzpatrick
would be there and so that's right so I
I did think Fitzpatrick will be there he
seems like a guy that would take to the
grill and just be you know he'd be like
beer in one hand spatula and the other
just just doing it right I can I say so
it may offend you please okay I sent you
the clip of Ryan Fitzpatrick yes I where
I found an old Food Network where his
wife was like Ryan's never in the
kitchen I the way this is the level
we're at you're now watching like old
Food Network's Rachael Ray I want to
know what things are going on in your
life that you're putting off so that you
can do research and this I was gonna say
daddy cigars that's what's creating this
but I also factored this in and don't be
offended I also was like you went to
Harvard Oh what are you gonna do okay
all right so just tell everyone tell
everybody I think we need to establish
this what that I went to Harvard to
Harvard okay and I've asked you this
before about Ryan Fitzpatrick it's got
to be someone annoying where you go to
this prestigious School and I'm sure
other people are like yeah but you're
not gonna get your hands dirty so I like
that's [ __ ] right like I factor that
in but I know it's [ __ ] and I
apologize I mean I went there I want to
publicly an acknowledge it the version
of Harvard that people have in their
minds yes he's like the social network
where it's all just Winklevoss twins
yeah they're like millionaires that hire
people so happy were talking with I'm
telling you man it was a college just
like anything else there was a range of
people it's a very diverse place there's
a lot of different kinds of people from
a lot of different places and there's a
lot of people from the Midwest that love
grilling then and love nothing more than
playing cornhole out by the Charles
River when it was a nice day I just
wanted to like publicly state my bias in
this rank I'm not gonna do it again but
I wanted to have the talk because I
imagine that as much as people go right
with Patrick he went to Harvard there's
also people that are like that probably
questioned him for a long time look
because of it which is so funny to me
would you also say that like anyone that
went to a state school all they did was
party they didn't buckle down and do
their studies it's like of course you
wouldn't say that but if somebody went
to Wisconsin in the back of my head I'd
be like that dude likes beer I would
that's how that's how simple my brain is
right but like yeah I'm just I'm not a
fan of saying like all Canadians are
polite thousand per you know although
I'm very well aware that what I did was
completely biased and rooted in nothing
I just want you know it's just it's it's
one of the few schools where I feel like
it has that it's the sort of thing when
you have when you have nothing else to
go on
sure use the fact that like okay we have
these biases against or
for certain things to lump someone in
with a certain category I don't fault
you for doing that because there is a
finite amount of information on these
grilling skills of these quarterbacks
but I will say that I know plenty of
folks out there that went to Harvard
with me that are very skilled in areas
you might not have a thousand the other
thing is that I've learned Jameis was up
there because you're also gonna get some
crab legs and I watched an old Hard
Knocks where they had like two or three
old metal steel barbecues and he was
back there hanging out it's also this
incredible Hard Knocks clip where he
sips from a faucet off the side of his
house and then immediately goes but be
careful the pee we all pee in this part
of the yard and like I can't clip that
out but I want to put it on YouTube so
bad
Big Ben has his own barbecue sauce and
restaurants which I learned luck Andrew
Luck is a foodie but he talked so much
about serving fine cheeses that I had to
realize he might take this a direction
of a barbecue that I'm not looking for
I'm he might bring out like a roasted
duck which is great but it might upset
some people because we're not doing the
traditional stuff dude that's fantastic
though I that's why he's in the top ten
I'm telling you if you show up to a
barbecue and they've got an unexpected
dish you celebrate that person and I
mean anyone can make hotdogs and
hamburgers I'm not knocking those off
for table time but if you show up and
they've got something you know some sort
of smoked brisket with an interesting
chili rub and you're like okay then
let's get it going
that's why he's top ten I have Jimmy G
ahead of him I talked to some of his
teammates hmm and they called him a
grill master right I saw him so when
they told me that he'd he'll do the
Italian sausages and the peppers and
onions I was like that's an experience
I'm down for that
props to Jimmy for being a good cook
yeah I promise for that I will say the
clip that you sent me though where he's
at a class learning how to make Pinot it
was it was more he was like Lou
Malnati's and they were like teaching
him how to make like the traditional
Chicago slices I'm glad you got oh
that's cool I'm glad that you got the
inside knowledge because based on that
clip alone yeah
I've seen you know I've watched pretty
much every Gordon Ramsay clip on YouTube
at this point and there's times where
he's learning from another master chef
how to do something and he's got this
this
proficiency in the kitchen where he says
oh oh that oh that's interesting the way
you're doing that he's all excited and
he's with it he's he's just raring to go
Jimmy Garoppolo looked like he couldn't
have been more miserable in the kitchen
like okay so now what do I do
yeah I do this this is everything this
is every cooking show guy reaches for
parsley Guy Fieri
so parsley yeah a little bit of parsley
the guy reaches for cumin ah cumin is
gonna give a nice flavor and then after
he eats it he goes you can really taste
the parsley
I like the hints of the cumin I also and
I'm like all cooking shows are are
people just talking about ingredients
out pouring them in making the thing and
then re saying ingredients great move is
to Google the wine that your table just
ordered in the bathroom and then come
back out and be like mmm listen
persimmon that's I could really taste
the wind of the hill notes of cinnamon
the bottom five it went from the the
worst I had at Kirk Cousins yeah
above that Tom Brady above that Eli
Manning you above that ever make it out
of the top 30 well that's when we have
to figure out this week right then Cam
Newton then Russell Wilson Wilson cam
and Brady are all there because they're
either never cooking or they're not
eating meat at all and I thought it was
more insulting to Eli to be below cam
because look people are getting so angry
me about Eli right now sure and it's so
funny that I want to challenge us to
think other than could catch the most
flies with their mouths open
what would a lie have to get number one
it most punchable face youth Peyton
trivia ooh he probably knows the most
about seven-year-old Peyton Manning of
anyone in the league and that would be
really funny to do like such a blatantly
obvious it's like he lies at number one
and everyone else is essentially tied at
second most likely to be in a movie in
which tin sells a book about you Aaron
Rodgers I had six to last because I
found this old TMZ clip of him and Chris
Pratt burning a steak hmm on of on a
shared vacation couples retreat you know
what that is though that's an
opportunity to learn and get better in
the future every every grill master
every chef has burned a steak and
they've said okay what I did was I did
too much of this or not enough of this
or too much heat too early they
give that out and they adjusted the
calibrate it's what great chefs do my
problem with air in those I feel like
he's gonna be like well that's how you
got it you know what I mean like he's
that one it's like sorry steaks are
burned oh he just plonk sit down yeah
he's just moving on he's moving on but
from were there any other ones that you
definitely want to talk about
look I I've said this before and I'll
say it again young people just can't be
in my top 20 I got you young people just
don't have the reps on the grill and and
that's true at anywhere you grow up like
even if like let's say your family was
very into grilling it was like by 16 or
17 you've had a few hours at the grill
you just don't have that that burned
wrist that your nachos that that
seasoning that you that you develop over
time I tried I didn't have too many
young guys I know Watson's up there I
found about a dozen tweets on his
Twitter that is him like sampling
different barbecues
I also factored region and deshaun
Watson being in Houston right now is
like an up-and-coming region I also seem
to favor guys that were from the south
right that makes sense I mean that was
just why I'm also like no slack oh like
if you stand that long in the pocket you
probably burn your food like if your
awareness is that low he's also like six
seven and that must be a difficult hunch
you know hunched over to try to get that
I'd much rather be like six one at the
grill grow so is there a hot anything
event but what I'm gonna factor in what
I do think was interesting was I go on
to Instagram on Saturday and the thing
that I love about the homies and the 33%
is if there's a story that I may have
talked about her I might like they're
gonna alert me hey man look at this
mm-hmm and he very slyly on Saturday
Kirk Cousins posted a picture on his
Instagram story and he wrote grilling on
a Saturday night and I want to pull it
out right now so that I'm not the only
one that has seen this but he a Saturday
night grilling out Allegan Michigan and
when I saw that went look at Kirk look
at the size of that grill the steaks
looks really great but then I zoomed in
Kirk and I realized that doesn't look
like your equipment and there's other
stuff on the other side and
zoomed in and there's a waitress with a
t-shirt and when I realized he's in a
restaurant there's a display case in the
front where all that so Kirk while
eating out on a Sunday Saturday night
went into the kitchen of a restaurant my
rankings came out on Thursday right and
felt the need to put out there Saturday
night grilling are you guys in touch
before like his he DMD you about various
tweets like I have interviewed him
before but I've never been able to talk
to him oh you're on you're on his radar
apparently so you think that so what I'm
thinking is that Kirk Cousins was made
aware of the grilling rankings and he's
trying to put out there that he's a
better griller and in doing so he got
totally caught in the lie this is like
no one could be a bigger scandal that
when Kevin Durant had the burner
accounts is what I'm saying it's
interesting I think because one I
completely agree with you and two it's
not a scandal yet Kirk I saw what you
were doing and while I understand that
you're trying to get back in the good
graces the grillmaster rankings that was
a bad step we're willing to fix that
here though what if though we're cousins
in your words it's time to grill Kirk
Cousins yeah Kirk I want to have you on
this show and the only thing I want to
talk about is barbecue and I'm not gonna
ask you about your connection with Filan
and Diggs I'm not gonna talk to you
about you know Stefanski in the new
offense I want to talk to you about
season meets grill marks and how much
time you do before you flip over a
burger correct answer six minutes so
Kirk Cousins people are coming at you
man from putting tinfoil down on the
barbecue to unseasonal assed year to now
me realizing that you were portraying a
griller I'd like to have you on to talk
about cooking meats Kirk Cousins is an
open invitation if it does turn out
though that he was at the restaurant and
he was like hey would it be cool if I
Kurt cousins just man to your grill for
a couple hours and just like banged out
a couple of sea bass for the people in
the restaurant I got some training that
if he actually manned the grill for 45
minutes pretty much sweating and then at
one point ding de Bell and said order up
Table six sealed off the hairnet and
said
all right let's do this eighty-six the
bacon but that's what I think I need to
do with Kirk
I think Kirk needs a little bit of a
master class right I think he learns a
little bit right right right but when I
saw that there was one word that came
into my head davening ber starts to the
w it ends with an O and that word is big
offseason
nice job audio man Nick great timing
you got two O's we're doing two O's
after a July 4th huh yeah that was a
four-day weekend you're gonna make me
pack this into just two woes I can pick
my favorite two for sure there's so many
wolves out there like they are never
cook Dalvin cook working out on a beach
Mohamed Sanu throws it over a kids house
but these are more quotes right your man
Eddie Jackson yes big season last year
for Chicago right he says quote our goal
right now is for our defense to be
number one across the board shoutout to
the 85 Bears but we want to top
everything they've done hallowed ground
right here that's a that's a call out to
me there are a few teams that no matter
what decade were in it's kind of like
talking about the Celtics in the 60s or
the Lakers in the 70s I mean the 85
Bears the manic 96 Bulls 85 Bears
absolutely yeah and in terms of the NFL
it's like defenses everybody really
knows the top teams 85 Bears 2000 Ravens
2002-2003 Bucks the Seahawks in the
early 2010's and there's a lot of teams
enter that I'm not talking about the
Broncos a few years ago when they won
but the Bears especially in that town
are untouchable oh yeah Jim McMahon Mike
Singletary Ditka buddy Ryan the
refrigerator Perry if it's immortal and
so many of those guys are in the Hall of
Fame what's interesting about this to me
and the reason I make it a whoa is I've
been noticing a lot of quotes like this
Jacksonville Jaguars Hayden comes out
and goes we're gonna be the best defense
the NFL it is
I saw CJ Mosley came out and said
everybody's sleeping on the Jets it is
the season to talk about how you're
gonna punch everybody in the face this
year but the Bears if you look if you
think back to the MENA Kimes episode she
was down on the Bears I'm a little down
on the Bears what's really interesting
to me as Mitchell try Biscay has become
the most bet on quarterback or excuse me
the most bet on MVP pick in Vegas right
now because he's got sexy odds this D
and they went from sexy to not sexy at
all because so many people bet him right
but what Mena chyme said is why I'm
going to caution everyone about picking
the Bears too in the north Vic Fangio
left and as much as Vic Fangio when he
goes to a new team do they immediately
have success and we saw seen this in San
Francisco and in Chicago when he leaves
the defense falls apart right we've seen
that in San Francisco so I would say
that listening to Eddie Jackson talk
about how the defense is gonna dominate
again I think it's very unlikely for
Khalil Mack to have back-to-back seasons
like that and I do think that they're
gonna take a step back and I do worry
that calling your shot with the 85 Bears
is just something that I may have to
bookmark for the end of the year not to
rub it in to Eddie Jackson but just be
like this is why things are whoa in the
offseason I I just don't like when when
athletes say [ __ ] like this and then
they take a lot of heat from it because
I love where you're going right now what
would you rather him say like we're just
gonna try to be pretty good was that
what you'd rather him say cuz athletes
say [ __ ] like that all the time and
pressors and it's boring as hell and
it's not good content I love that you
said that I had this argument with Malik
Jackson cuz every year he would say
we're winning the Superbowl why wouldn't
and I'd say it's a whoa because that's
what he's supposed to say yeah it's more
news if Eddie Jackson goes honestly I
think we're gonna take a step back next
season then it's news then it's news you
know what I mean cuz Gordon but I
completely agree with you like if you
know Nikhil Harry comes out or Andy
Isabella comes out they're like I want
to be better than the Jerry Rice or
Larry Fitzgerald it's like cool you
should want to be better than them
you're a rookie coming into the league
what do you want to be mediocre yeah you
want to be
best ever I do I do think though that
it's it's interesting when you start
calling out the historical teams because
it's so deeply rooted in that fan base
like I'm waiting for someone to go we're
gonna make a run at the 1972 dolphins
undefeated season that's awesome that's
what they should say you make a run at
it I'm ready for that to end and here's
the thing it's smart right like okay so
let's say someone on the raven said
we're gonna be better than the 85 Bears
the Bears fans would be up in arms over
this but someone from the Bears says
they want to be better than the 85 Bears
the Chicago the the downside is the team
isn't very good the upside is the team
is incredible so no matter what happens
like either the 85 Bears stays hallowed
ground in your mind yes or the 2019
bears are amazing former teams only grow
in their mythology
yes it's why I don't think LeBron will
ever surpass Jordan in most people's
minds because every time you go out you
see a Jordan logo mm-hmm he's always
stretching for the free-throw line dunk
he only gets better the longer he's
retired the 85 Bears will become more
dominating the 2000 Ravens will become
more suffocating right but the defense
is this year they might let up three
touchdowns in week two and we're all
over them right as warren sharp face
times me warren sharps interview coming
up in a second ah the other whoa ho man
it's a beautiful one isn't it yeah this
is why Manning who has yet to get to
crack the anything out of the bottom
three in any of your ranking I gotta
figure out what we're gonna do the quote
is funny he says quote I'm not rushing
into retirement and Payton's not telling
me to rush into it
Eli said via nola.com I still love being
around the guys and teammates playing
this game I'm not gonna play for as long
as I think I can hang with these guys
and this this actually was a really good
great quote he said in the locker room I
feel their age at 8 o'clock at night I
don't feel their age I'm ready to go to
bed and they're just getting started
rocking and rolling I can't hang and do
everything that they can off the field
wit self-awareness we marvel at Tom
Brady at 42 43 beating his old 40 time
and all that we marvel at Drew Brees and
his longevity and how he's used his
brain him and Brady really and rivers to
to manipulate defenses into
advantage we marvel at Big Ben's ability
to still have one the strongest arms the
NFL and constantly put up points and I
feel like we're watching Eli Manning
right now and we're all going whenever
you want to retire man like no one's
marveling about anything about Eli
Manning his teammates still love him
peyton has talked about not wanting to
broadcast games because he didn't want
to criticize Eli which I think speaks
volumes about where Eli's current play
has been right Eli's almost a sicker
burn exactly I don't want to talk crap
about my brother I literally can't he
can't broadcast the games without
talking crap about him Eli is likely to
enter the top seven by the end of this
year of interceptions alt I saw that of
all the statistical categories that are
available for quarterbacks the only one
Eli has ever led in a season is
interceptions the year before the Ben
McAdoo season this the Giants are in
such a predicament that it's crazy
now they've drafted the heir apparent in
Daniel Jones but I don't know how this
transitions gonna go yeah
Eli is coming out and constantly saying
I'm not even thinking about retirement
right which means he's not going to make
this easy on you do you think they're
gonna trade him they do a little Joe
Montana to Kansas City situation I don't
think they can they I've said it so many
times it's like annoying to listeners
I'm sure that they had their opportunity
when they benched from that one time I
went to Geno they went right back but I
don't know how they're gonna do this
because Gettleman is so obsessed with
doing right by Eli and I feel like the
Francesa the world have controlled
Giants fans narratives to like we have
to do right by Eli that this whole
transition man is gonna be really sloppy
I mean great as a as a non Giants fan
great agree with more sloppiness it's
great I don't care it's I don't even
know the last time we've had because
like you talked about Montana and young
and that should have been really hard
but when you have someone like Bill
Walsh that can look someone in the eye
and go I'm getting rid of you right
everyone it's like if Bella check
whenever he goes to Brady and goes we're
moving on no one will question
a check I mean they do but then three
years later he's proven to have made the
right decision sorry I was asking you
again but they do question him the next
time how could you trade Christian Jones
will be fine yeah
Chandler Jones will be fine yeah Oh
Jamie Jamie Colin see buddy
he's amazing is the heart of the defense
and then we win this yes so you need to
have a coach that has all of like Andy
Reid can move on from a quarterback or
Pete Carroll but Pat Shermer has only
been there for like two years
yeah and and and everyone's questioning
gentlemen all the time the only way it
makes it easy is if Eli is not doing
well and Daniel Jones comes in and is
killing it mm-hmm
what if Daniel Jones doesn't kill it
right away and he doesn't have to
because he's a rookie and he's not
supposed to and they have no wide
receivers so if Daniel Jones doesn't
kill it right away this could get really
bad and what you want is the the Patrick
mahomes where we all remember Patrick's
rookie year when he wasn't playing but
we were hearing those murmurs oh just
him lighting it up in practice yes and
by the time it was Patrick mahomes his
team he didn't feel that pressure of
like oh you better be good because Alex
Smith we got rid of Alex Smith for you
but exactly like at that point we were
ready it was Patrick mahomes his team
and that is the best thing that could
happen at Daniel Jones is Eli Manning
has a nice swan song year he plays well
and Daniel Jones were just hearing
rumors about how throwing bb's in
practice and you know he's winning over
the locker room yes making good speeches
and he's a lot of one teammate holding
that clipboard up but I want to I want
to apologize to the Giants fans if I
feel like I'm piling it on I'm really
bringing this story because I'm trying
to have empathy for you right because I
look around the NFL it's gonna be really
hard for the Saints to move on from Drew
Brees whenever that happens because I
don't think Drew's gonna want to hang
them up it's gonna be really hard for
the Steelers to move on from Big Ben as
Big Ben kind of threw down the gauntlet
this offseason and out goes Antonio
Brown and out goes levy on bail and Big
Ben who two years ago said I might
retire is now saying I don't want to
retire right and it's gonna be and these
are all like the same draft class it's
gonna be really hard for the FIR rivers
and and the Chargers burgers might play
forever he's gonna try to even though at
the end of the year that arm kind of
falls off but
these guys don't want to stop can I
throw out one suggestion yeah so did you
know that racehorses they travel with a
goat to keep them company
I'm not kidding like racehorses are very
expensive to travel around if you bring
a goat you can just throw them in the
trailer right so I'm thinking for these
quarterbacks once they get to be like 37
38 39 years old and the entire locker
room is twenty four year olds right
you just bring in like Matt Hasselbeck
or somebody you know just hang out with
your Aging quarters yeah just leave
someone to talk about movies and music
with yeah I'm gonna travel with like in
the hotel they can both like eat dinner
at 6:30 and then yeah bed by 8:00 is
that a terrible use of $500,000 a year I
think that's what a lot of NFL teams do
like a wheat when we had michael vick in
here and he was like dude i was better
than almost all the backup quarterbacks
they want the sean hills they want those
guys that are super non-threatening they
that should be a special roster spot
just called like ordered old
quarterbacks friend QB pal yeah i think
part of the reason why GM's level
quarterbacks as they can reason with
them like they bring them in the room
and they're like we can't talk about
eric clapton right i mean yeah whereas
like i can't connect with gerald peppers
you know like i don't get it do you
remember Ace of Base when they were
coming up they were awesome weren't they
yeah yeah all right so let's get to
warren sharp Warren's new book the 29
football preview he watches every single
play writes down observations that he
sees across the NFL and then breaks it
down you can get it at sharp football
analysis dot-com here's my interview
with Warren Sharpe and is now time to
officially welcome in the man the myth
felishj the legend warren sharp sharp
football I have his book and if you went
on social media and all the last two
weeks you've seen everyone buying his
book Warren sharps 2019 football preview
warrant Warren takes all of his
information pours it in over months and
gets you ready for the NFL season if you
want to buy it it's actually a lot
cheaper than going on Amazon and you're
helping out Warren go to sharp football
analysis dot-com it says also as a new
website they're relaunching but more of
the money if you get the PDF goes to
Warren so I'm trying to hook them up but
Warren is joining us from the
Outer Banks of North Carolina and you've
earned yourself a little vacation my man
congratulations
thank you for the kind introduction Adam
definitely happy to be with you again
and I love your show love for everything
what you're doing there and Bleacher and
happy to join you again
well the 33% always appreciates you
let's start off as a person when I'm
seeing Colin Cowherd and and all these
NFL people tweeting publicly I can't
wait to get Warren's book I know it
wasn't always like this I'm sure you
felt like more of an outsider
what has this year felt like yeah I
definitely you know feel like pretty I
don't want to say integral but just like
more well-connected part of the NFL
community from a broad picture I mean
obviously I deal with sports betting but
I'm also involved with analytics working
for a couple of different NFL teams as a
consultant so certainly more people are
made aware of my work and I've got a
bigger platform to kind of inform people
from and I enjoy doing that I love you
know that's what the reason I built all
the things that I'm doing especially
with sharp football stats which is this
pretty stats website you know it's just
trying to share information with people
try to share good information and more
importantly information that is not
readily out there that other people are
sharing you know I'm not like a new
source I'm trying to find dig into
things analyze in a different way and
share new information with people I
think what we've had a lot on this
podcast lately whether it's you or the
fantasy footballers or guys like Pat
McAfee our guys that are building their
own and I think it's really cool but to
get to your book last year I think what
you really hit on extensively was early
down success rate and why our team's not
throwing the ball on first down two
running backs or tight ends in the
middle of the field instead of running
the ball on first running the ball on
second you've tried to you really banged
your head against the wall stopped
running on second and ten
but it seems like the NFL as a whole has
adopted this and I feel like in this
book you're talking a lot on let's use
play ax
and more when we're throwing it let's
throw to slot receivers and let's throw
more out of 12 and 21 so when you have
two running backs or two tight ends is
is that the message of this year's book
is let's continue to throw more on first
down but then also focus more on slots
and 12 and 21 personnel definitely in a
way that's a big part of what I have
found in my research
crunching clay by play data charting
data to be more efficient ways to
utilize personnel more efficient types
of plays to call um you know from from
the when we're talking about clay action
a lot of that is what I refer to as you
know pre snap motion and post snap
motion
I know people call post not motion as a
quote unquote thing but pre snap motion
is very useful to help the quarterback
identify what the coverage is try to
help dictate matchups you know send your
guy off to this side and see who he's
going to follow him or align with him
those are things that the offense can
get clues from the defense before us
anything even happened such that you
have an edge over the defense more teams
need to you to like that but when we're
talking about play-action I kind of
refer to that as post snap motion it's a
way to utilize motion through a running
back that's running a certain direction
in this case right next to the
quarterback pretending to take the ball
on a handoff to again try to get the
defense to react in some capacity so
that it's easier for the offense I think
that offensive coordinators need to be
doing every single thing within their
power to make things easier for the
offense every single time the ball is
snapped and when you can utilize
different pre and post snap motion
that's one way to do that cadence you
know your ability to use cadence and
hard counts situational usage of tempo
you're gaining Carolina in scrimmage
quickly in a certain situation don't
just always go fast just to go fast but
get to line of scrimmage quickly to keep
a certain defensive unit out on the
field and then call a specific play that
will counter that personnel in a very
efficient manner and then of course
where you
mentioned which is beyond pre or post
that motion it's when you have the
stoppage in play between plays bring on
the right types of personnel that are
going to see more success we talked a
lot about in the last book using a
little bit more passing discussion on
first down and the league is trending
more in that direction you some teams
are being dragged kicking and screaming
that way but the morale is more tuned
for passing but what they're doing is
they're simply passing from 11 personnel
three wide receivers one running back
one where they're really going to pass
yeah where they're clearly going to pass
and they're just you know dictating it a
little bit before the snap some teams
have a lot of tendency the defense can
figure out and when you utilize 12 and
21 personnel then you're giving the air
of some confusion you're causing the
defense a little bit of consternation
before the stuff what are they going to
do here and so it's all about increasing
your advantage before the ball is even
snapped with making the defense not have
a good idea of what you're going to do I
think what's so interesting is we have
pounded the table for so long for every
team to use pre snap motion for every
team to do play-action and I think
what's interesting is we can applaud the
teams that are doing it but they should
have been doing it and I'm sure as you
go through every single play which I
know you do
there are certain teams that frustrate
you because it's as if they're not
learning from anything so I'm curious
through watching every play last season
born who are the three teams that
impressed you the most and who are the
three teams that frustrated you the most
well you know the impressive teams some
of them unfortunate are similar to what
we've grown accustomed to right I think
the New England Patriots are a team that
they use a ton of 21 personnel they do
things a little bit differently 21 they
have a fullback out there most of the
time so James Devlin is the guy who's
out there and most of time they do run
from that but they also can pass they
were a really creative team from that
perspective I was also impressed with
some of the things that the Philadelphia
Eagles did particularly with Carson
Wentz because I don't think enough of is
taken into context with the sea
not he delivered because two years ago
when they won the Super Bowl you know
that was a season when he was so good at
converting on these third and Long's and
I know you're a fan and so you remember
the way that they ran the table to get
to the Super Bowl is a lot of these
passes almost like well it's third and
nine you know we don't really have a
shot all of a sudden boom they converted
you know 12-yard gain the last year they
were a lot more efficient on first and
second downs and the other thing to take
into the consideration is that he was
playing with a broken bone in his back
to end the season obviously and to start
the season he was coming off of an ACL
injury and he still delivered the year
that he did I think on the opposite end
of the spectrum in terms of a couple
teams that were more frustrating one of
which has to be the Washington Redskins
and just the way that I kind of
unfortunately predicted that this would
happen with the way that they utilized
Adrian Peterson as their running back
and you know John sorry Jay Gruden was a
little bit too much run-heavy on first
down it set the team up in very bad
tough situations to overcome that was
extremely extremely frustrating watching
that oftens perform of course they lost
Alex Smith very early in the season like
halfway through and so you know the fans
had these high expectations because the
team was winning games but I wrote a lot
in the chapter on the Redskins they
really weren't as oppressive as their
record indicated another team that
frustrated me from a pure play calling
perspective was the Tennessee Titans
you know they won nine games so they
were a winning team they had a shot they
were a successful team if you want to
determine you know did you have a
winning season or not but I was not a
fan whatsoever
what about Matt Lafleur and the way that
he was calling plays and the strategies
he was utilizing you know we wanted to
get rid of Mount Lafleur I sorry we
wanted to get rid of Mike Mularkey
because of his insistence on running the
football but he actually was running the
football more frequently and less
successfully in than either season of
the exotics smashmouth of Mike Mularkey
the prior two seasons so Matt Lafleur
was definitely a disappointment to me
from that perspective and then I guess
you would call this a disappointment to
beat the third team would be the Seattle
Seahawks again
I'm calling on teams that have had some
winning records but the way I approach
things is it's easy to say you know oh
well a team like the you know Miami
Dolphins or you know another bad team
last year like the Detroit Lions was a
disappointment or the Denver Broncos I'm
looking at teams that I had higher
expectations out of or have key players
that could have performed in Seattle
with Russell Wilson that's a that's a
franchise quarterback well deserving of
the money that is being paid and you
know their last season with Doug Baldwin
as it turned out and they still won 10
game but the way they were calling plays
in the strategies they were utilizing
was very frustrating to me to watch I
will add one last team I'll know if
we're going to get to them and on the
other discussion so I might as well
throw it in here that exceeded my
expectations a little bit and this seems
funny for the people listening because
they had a losing record a really bad
record in fact but the San Francisco
49ers what Kyle Shanahan did with that
team they actually were one of two teams
to finish top ten and early down success
rate a metric that I utilize on offense
and in defense it's a really strong
metric they finished top ten both
offense and defense and they won four
games but they had to cycle through a
number of different quarterbacks there
with the early injury the Jimmy
Garoppolo I was very impressed with how
they were in a ton of their games he had
nine games that were decided by one
score or less so that was just a team
that I think has good opportunities to
perform well this year that a lot of
people probably will overlooking and
thought that they were really terrible
because they only won four games last
year but they really had a better year
than their final record indicated how
does your view of Lafleur and Tennessee
impact your projection of the Green Bay
offense which I know a lot of people in
the fantasy community right now we're
getting very excited about Aaron Rodgers
and those wide receivers and he more
utilized Aaron Jones how does this
Lafleur review impact your projection
well the one thing that I liked about
what Lafleur did in Tennessee was
throwing the football to his running
back so that's something that you know
both Kyle Shanahan which is some of what
look for is the influence as well as
Sean McVeigh both of those coaches throw
a lot to their running backs and they
did that a lot down in Tennessee and I
hope that that's what's going to be the
most
major and most noticeable change in
Green Bay because those passes we've
talked about it before particularly the
passes on first down and second down to
your running backs they're not going to
gain as many yards per play as a throw
to a wide receiver is because the you
know the average air yard the distance
downfield the depth of target is
significantly shorter most time when you
throw it to the running doc he's two
three yards behind the line of scrimmage
whereas a wide receiver is going to be
five plus yards past the line of
scrimmage but it's not as much how many
yards are being it's that their kin
contributing a successful play to the
offense they're keeping the offense
ahead of the down and distance ahead of
the sticks so to speak and that's one
thing that you know the old coach
they're in Mike McCarthy was very anti
throw the football two running backs and
they were they I think for the prior
three years had the worst or the second
worst in terms of usage utility rate
towards their running back throwing in
the passes this offense is going to
change a lot from that perspective and I
think Aaron Jones is going to get a lot
more targets out of the backfield so I
think that's a really good thing okay I
think it's good thing that they're going
to have a little bit more play-action to
that offense and you know I'm excited
with the opportunities that they have
because I think Aaron Rodgers you know a
lot of the analytics crowd be kind of
like the new AG analytics crowd is a
little bit anti Aaron Rodgers like all
the staff haven't been that great the
last few years and and this and that but
I'm really am hoping that like I don't
buy into that necessarily I think he is
one of the best quarterbacks that we
have in a league he was playing most of
the season last year I like with a major
knee injury sure would have limited most
quarterbacks out there so I think
Rodgers is clearly one of the best that
we have in the league and I think as bad
as Lafleur was with Tennessee last year
I'm hoping that he gets a little bit
better with a quarterback like Aaron
Rodgers instead of you know with Marcus
Mariota who we had last year one of the
things I valued from your book so much
last year was looking at strength of
schedule before making my season long
predictions and it's part of the reason
why I picked the Texans to win the south
was because in your schedule they had
the easiest schedule right there with
the Patriots and last year the team that
had the hardest
schedule was the Cardinals and I think
that kind of played out and I'm curious
as you looked at the strength of
schedules for these teams going forward
who came out to be in the easiest and
who came out to be in the toughest as
you looked ahead right and and your
astutely noted that I didn't actually
include a strength I said the article in
the 2019 book now I will be publishing a
strength of schedule article shortly on
the website but the most interesting
schedule to discussed by far is the
Houston Texans because the Houston
Texans played the number one easiest
schedule is alluded to last year that's
why they had a good record I thought you
know the running back was in a good
position from a fantasy perspective last
season and their team obviously would
exceed expectations right this year they
played the NFL's most difficult schedule
oh wow so just like that it goes from
easiest to most difficult in one season
in one season in one fell swoop
it switches from the easiest to the most
difficult and so that is what one of the
reasons I'm very you know down this on
this defense this defense played the
number one easiest schedule of opposing
quarterbacks last year I wrote a lot
about how easy the quarterbacks were
like if you could have written out old
like out of 60 or 40 quarterbacks in the
league I would love to play like B's
like 10 quarterbacks sure they played
most of those 10 right it was it was
ludicrous that that types of
quarterbacks that they were playing last
year I mean a lot of them were like okay
look at this Brock Osweiler Blaine
Gabbert
Blake bortles Kody Kessler Colt McCoy
Case Keenum Nathan Peterman Marcus
Mariota like they were playing those
quarterbacks a death sentence will lift
a terrible quarterbacks in the league
that's literally who they played and
this year they have to face a lot more
difficult quarterback so that's the most
glaring schedule and I'm looking at
their their over/under right now is an
eight and a half and so that's one of
those things where do you felt like when
you see a trend like that do you
automatically start thinking under I do
because I weigh in first of all I
calculate shrinking schedule only
differently that most people do I don't
want
right so I don't look at win rate from
last year what I look at is projected
wind totals for this upcoming season set
by the guys who are actually taking
significant money on them the guys out
in Las Vegas so your season palace those
sports books those oddsmakers we're
putting lines on these games
I am incorporating those into my
forecast and then I'm looking at who
they play each week and what's their
average schedule of opponent and then I
rank it league wide and so I look at it
from that perspective than when I do I
can put a lot more weight on strength of
schedule my opinion of strength is
schedule more firm and strength is
schedule if you're saying oh well this
is the 15 pieces the twelfth most
difficult schedule versus the 20th like
that's not as big of a deal where it's
valuable to look at is the extremes and
when you take a team that face the
easiest and now go to the hardest
absolutely that is where I would not
look at the over for the Houston Texans
whatsoever this upcoming season how
about the flipside did anyone have a
really tough schedule last year and its
flipped to the easier one this year that
we can maybe look at that over yeah
there's a number of teams one of which
in the case of the Cleveland Browns
moved dramatically significantly easier
last year they played the third most
difficult overall schedule and this year
that I've got them playing the fourth
easiest schedule in the league I'll just
list off the top four schedule if it's
up but in front of the Browns who are
the fourth easiest you have two teams
that are likely maybe going to the Super
Bowl the Patriots and the Eagles both
play very easy schedules and then you
also have the Jets with Sam darn 'old
who face a the number two most easy
schedule in the league so the Patriots
the Jets the Eagles and then the Browns
play the four easiest schedules in the
league and one of which that it is a big
flip is the Cleveland Browns now
offensively
it does get more difficult for them but
defensively it gets substantially easier
for them so things you know last year
was interesting Baker Mayfield if you
look at the splits and when he performed
you could split him up by the defenses
types of Defense's that he faced when he
played bad defenses he crushed them I
mean he was astonishingly great when he
played the good defenses though he
tended to struggle and last shouldn't
surprise us he's a rookie we didn't even
start the year as a
you know he wasn't getting you first
team reps you Jackson wouldn't let him
in training camp but you know that was
something notable and this year they
play much more difficult past defenses
however their own defense should crush
I think the Cleveland Browns defense
should have a very good year from like a
fantasy perspective lower point totals
allowed because they play a very easy
schedule compared to what they played
last year last year they played the
third most difficult schedule of
opposing offenses in the league this
year they play the 10th easiest hmm
alright so I'm gonna kind of wrap it up
after this but I'm curious now that you
get through the book and well this is
what happens to a lot of people just for
my listeners out there that we all are
paying attention to football all the
time but until you really sit down and
really look at everything and factor
everything in you don't even know what
you don't know now that you've gone
through everything and the book is
published and your website is officially
launched
are there any overs and unders I know
last year dude you were pounding Buffalo
and the under who are the teams that are
exciting you the most right now where
you think Vegas and the public is wrong
well it's a challenge because I have yet
to actually issue recommendations you
know I don't know I don't want to steal
the Thunder yeah well I have to hit you
back up maybe like another little quick
podcast where we bang out some of these
once I've had a chance to actually get
down on them now there's a couple of
dabbles here and there but you know
limits are shorter earlier on I will say
at my advice in general to people who
are betting these short is look we are
only like two weeks out from the start
of training camps and we we know that
there's a lot of injuries that tend to
occur at the beginning of training camps
so if you're looking to play and over
you may want to just be cautious like
there are teams that where there was a
little bit more value towards the over
earlier like potentially the
Philadelphia Eagles but you want to wait
if you're on a fence on a team you know
you're better off playing the under pick
the teams that you want to bet under and
do so sooner and take the teams that you
want to bet over and we wait and pull
the first Jews are good advice
because now you know the public one
thing to note that the public tends to
do is bet the overs so you're going to
find some teams that will have value if
it's a very public team like like you
know like the Eagles or Patriots or that
you want to if you want to go the office
way and bet those teams under some of
the times you're better off waiting
towards closer to the start of the
season to let all that over money come
in so the public tends to bet things
over but if you want to wait on to fade
them go ahead but if you want to get out
and note in front then going under on
some teams that are just mediocre now
it's better than waiting to see if some
of their injuries come up and they have
a problem later that is worn sharp right
now his book everybody is reading it if
you talk about the NFL Warren sharps
2019 football preview if you want to get
a copy and support him by downloading
the PDF and and read it anywhere
sharp football analysis calm it
officially launched Warren enjoy your
vacation you've earned it and we
appreciate all your knowledge my man
thanks for having me out I'm really
appreciate it alright brother I was like
a really professional closing it felt
like really good - thanks again - Warren
Sharpe for joining us and I just even
though he's at the beach I still think
he's wearing a blazer with a sweater
underneath and a perfectly combed
mustache of course just Warren Sharpe
yeah that's that's how he does man I
just I talked to these guys they're like
I have my vacation and he's hanging out
this house by the way with Evan Silva so
it's just like these two super football
minds hanging out for a week and I mean
Simmons used to say this all the time
that when Belichick would take vacation
he would go to like a place in Florida
or a place like South Carolina in North
Carolina and he'd go with like a Mike
Lombardi and they were just excuse me
sit outside of a hotel room like in
their back area with their laptops and
all their notes and we just go
isn't this great and they would just be
in warmth but also in the shade just
doing work and that was vacation that
sounds fun and the thing is is our
audience is we got teenagers we got kids
in their 20s
I am a transitioning adult I am a
recently engaged thinking about marriage
thinking about kids you're a been
married now for a few years have a
beautiful beautiful child and for a lot
of my listeners you know they're single
maybe dating and I think what's really
interesting is as you get older you get
so much more of a rush from like
accomplishing things then from
distractions where when I was growing up
if you told me you're gonna go and hang
out by the beach and do work for five
days where the parties where's the
drinking where's the daddy cigars
where's the bars and now if I like
getting to do that for five days sounds
amazing
in one of my favorite it's a weird
transition is when my wife takes the
baby and I've got a project like I have
to put together an IKEA dresser and I
just like have the like two or three
hours to myself it's a good quiet
apartment yes just like sitting there
with a beer and just putting together an
IKEA dresser ID and by the end I've made
a thing with my hands it just feels
great
I watched Letterman's interview with
Tiffany Haddish and they were gardening
and I was like Dan that sounds great and
then I was like the hell's wrong with me
that's that for those of you in your 20s
and below weird things are gonna start
how you turn 30 where you're like I just
want to like sit down in Journal for a
half hour I want to get my thoughts out
on paper yeah I just want to I want to
experiment with new you know extremely
adventurous egg recipes I think that's
the things like that just started
happening and you can't control them and
then I mean to connect what we were
talking about before Warren it's
probably the reason these older guys
don't want to leave because when they
were younger they're worried about you
know doing advertisements for Oreos and
all these distractions and now they're
like no all I want is to sit in a room
and watch plays for six hours like we
hear this all the time some athletes
they finally get that focus and that's
what you guys are gonna get as you get
older I'm just letting you know do you
think Belichick but on vacation he's
like I'm only gonna work a 10-hour day
today I'm gonna really like I mean I'm
not even gonna hit the hit the video
room until 9:00 balichek listens to the
specials at a restaurant or does he just
go to the restaurant knowing what he's
gonna
oh that's a great question because
Belichick does know what he likes but
he's also a very adaptable coach so if
he shows up and it turns out that
they've actually got mahi-mahi and it
sounds delicious he's like you know what
we're gonna throw out the playbook I'm
going mahi Morgan edition plenty more
citrusy wine he's now he's now in a new
game plan meanwhile Andy Reid sits down
and goes
I'll have this side thanks all right so
the the July 4th weekend was
commandeered by the NBA as is one to
happen my phone has never blown up more
and that includes my wedding day when I
was getting frantic text from everyone
in my family my phone has never blown up
more than that crazy free agents that's
awesome I decided to get notifications
for whoa and shammes
which made me seem really smart to my
friends cuz I'd be like uh-oh D'Angelo
Russell trade and they're like really
and I'm like yep I got sources it's like
no it's just watch I'm on Twitter
constantly right but I think what's
interesting is how the different
discussions evolve off of that the first
thing I thought was you know what NFL
player could move like kawaii what NFL
player could be really silent and would
have such a tight circle that nobody
would know what they were trying to do
right Rogers can I mine because I but I
know that he might leak stuff through
Mike silver and I just realized there
really isn't anyone the NFL that would
be doing that you can't compare NFL free
age you can't compare NBA free agency to
anything so what I would love to do for
the NFL to make it more of an event is I
want to almost have an NFL free-agent
draft where I want all of the big-name
free agents after the franchise tag
period they come to New York they sit in
a room they are the ones that go on
stage in their beautiful suit and put on
the Hat of the team they want to go to
oh like a high school senior juh Devi
and clowny goes on stage and goes I'd
like to take my talents to the New York
Jets flash bulbs because the NFL it's
just like it happens but because it's
before the draft too it's like like for
the NBA it's after the draft so it feels
really special then
I even went and I started thinking about
what players on teams right now could do
what the NBA players - and force a trade
if there was no franchise tag which
ruins a lot of these things who are the
guys that are coming up on their fifth
year option that could pull an Anthony
Davis and say I'm not staying after that
option so you might as well get
something for me right who are the guys
that are gonna be free agents next year
and I have a little bit of a list of
guys that I think if there were no
franchise tag who could take over NFL
free agency by the way are you a fan of
the franchise tag no I think it's awful
okay cool
like as this cba comes together the NFL
owners hold all of the rights the fact
that these NFL players are paid are on a
four-year contract right out of college
and the average lifespan of an NFL
player is three years is crazy right
when you then factor in if you're a
first-round pick they get a fifth year
option on you which is five years and
then when you factor and they can
franchise tag you not once but twice at
a reasonable number is the levy on bail
you are getting guys for seven years and
at seven years most of these guys are
already 30 right so their values gone
one more contract at that point props to
the NFL owners they have negotiated all
of the control and the own they own
these kids for a very long time I mean
the NBA is so careful that they're
changing the name of owners to governors
and the NFL is like no we know exactly
where we stand Jesus we know exactly
where we stand this is a tried and true
method for the NFL owners but I thought
who could buck this trend Jalen Ramsey
is at that time and I thought where
would he go Jalen Ramsey grew up and in
Nashville Tennessee if he were to push
them to leave for an AFC South arrival
and go to Tennessee that would blow up
the conversations be incredible all 30
Jacksonville Jaguars fans would be so
upset open arms Melvin Gordon he's
coming up on a new contract who knows
what they're gonna do for the Chargers
he's from Wisconsin I'll get him on the
pack what if
Melvin Gordon said I'm I want to go home
and I want to play for the Packers and
Aaron Rodgers and I want to he calls up
Aaron Rodgers like Kawai calls KD and
goes I'm very interested in playing with
you and they're like let's make this
happen
trade a second and third-round pick he's
leaving you anyway this is only if you
don't have the franchise tag but I
thought of the one guy who's in a
situation that might make a trade but
his contract isn't up anytime soon AJ
Green hmm I would love to reach a point
in the NFL where this guy is on a team
that's not going anywhere
he should be able to push his way out to
go on a different team and AJ Green to
me it's like he's had this career he's
gonna be a hall-of-famer
he's gonna go down as one the best wide
receivers of all time athletically he
should not have to stay on Cincinnati
his whole career so isn't this a
European soccer thing where if your team
is out of it but you've got some
SuperDuper star you can you can load
them to a contender for a couple of
months and you get a couple of
compensatory picks or something imagine
if you know your team is let's say two
and eight you're going nowhere and AJ
Green can join a contender can join the
Packers for the last few weeks of the
season in exchange for a future
second-round pick or something like that
yeah the playoffs would be so juiced all
the best guys would be playing in the
playoffs which is kind of what we want
here I am bringing up MBA stuff world
football soccer like that's the most
friendly to players they've done some
cool stuff you got like Messi's dad
getting 400 pounds this is four hundred
thousand pounds for just like being his
dad like it's so great but the thing
that I noticed when I talk about NFL
players and their salary versus NBA
players is that everybody likes to talk
about why there's a gap well the NBA
players have all the power and they they
play more games and the NFL players they
have helmets on you can give me all the
reasons why there's a gap I just need
you to understand how wide the gap is
when you look at it there are 26 excuse
me there are 35 NBA players
that are making more guaranteed money
than the highest-paid NFL player in
terms of guarantee right now carson
wentz nicolas Batum is getting more
guaranteed money than any player in the
NFL there's different ways to look at
this that just make you shake your head
and go this is wild Tobias Harris is
making to Khalil max Andre Andrew
Wiggins is making three DeAndre Hopkins
Landon Collins that monster deal the
people are going crazy in terms of
guaranteed money is one fourth of Chris
Middleton salary Chris Middleton is
awesome he's really good but when I look
at it it's really when you realize the
money they're making comparable when you
realize that DeAndre Hopkins is making
less than Kelly Olynyk in terms of
guaranteed money that Landon Collins is
making less than James Johnson then
Antonio Brown who did force his way out
and got a massive deal is making less
than Jeremy Lamb Blake Griffin is not
worth 10 Christian McCaffrey's Chris
Paul is not worth 10 Patrick mahomes but
he is Odell freaking Beckham is making
about the same as Ian Mahima let me say
that again for the people in the back
Odell Beckham jr.
is making about the same as Ian Mahinmi
we wonder why Zeke is demanding a new
contract he's making less than marquel
Fultz that's crazy I'm not saying that
it needs to change I'm not saying that
it's a it's a broken system
okay the NFL players not getting
guaranteed contracts in the one league
where their entire career isn't
guaranteed is crazy I just want to lay
it out for you the divide that Otto
Porter jr. is making more money than
Carson Wentz or Russell Wilson it's
blows me away that's a you you did your
homework you you found the numbers
they're the only argument is just like
in the NFL they seem to believe that we
don't have to pay levy on bail whatever
twenty million dollars a year because we
can get some guy coming out of Auburn
next year who's coming out of Georgia
that's gonna be great and we can pay him
you know four or five million I totally
under me it's it's I'm not trying to
poke holes and why it's more of just
like I was trying to wrap my brain about
all I hear is that the NFL is the number
one sport in America
nothing gets more money for television
rights the owners the Cleveland Browns
I'm gonna go to Warren Sharps book which
you can get on Sharpe analysis sharp
football analysis calm can you plug in
your friend because when you realize
it's literally the forward which makes
it so funny to me that Jimmy Haslam
bought the Browns in October of 2012
since he took over the record is 19 and
70 the value of his franchise has
appreciated by a billion dollars God
they are winning less than 22 percent of
their games and the owner improved the
value of his franchise by a Billy and
it's crazy to me that if an oh if Mark
Cuban could get into any sport he would
probably want to own an NFL team just on
terms of the amount of money that now I
know the NBA is like super valuable but
NFL teams are worth more than NBA teams
unless it's like the Lakers are the
Knicks right but it's just wild to me
when you read Odell and Mahinmi and it's
it's who's more famous who can bring in
more marketing dollars I totally
understand every reason why the NBA gets
more it's just more of when you say it
out loud you just feel like you're
taking crazy pills sometimes yeah I mean
if the if the NBA was playing 30 games a
year and said 82 and they had Shore 36
men rosters instead of 12 man rot or 15
man rosters yeah obviously the salaries
would shift there would be a massive
seismic shift in the way these players
are compensated right now the there's
there's a little bit of a cap on a free
market because of salary caps and
because of draft
this is the way certain free agency
rules work there's a little bit of a you
can't quite pay the guys what they're
worth like yes there was a few years and
there were LeBron James was essentially
worth eighty million dollars a year and
he was making sixteen totally but beyond
that like you just kind of have to trust
the system that if these guys want to
make more yeah there's unfortunately not
a market for that they capped them out
they like the best quarterbacks in the
world are making thirty or thirty five
million dollars a year and that's gonna
be the case for a while but the best
basketball player is gonna be making
forty to forty five million dollars a
year that's the way it goes that's the
that's what the market says I think
going through this what I've realized is
if I was the NFLPA and I was going into
the CBA the number one thing is that I
would fight for is removing the
restriction or the ability to use a
franchise tag more than once where you
want teams to be able to hold on to
players especially mid market teams
right I don't want Tennessee losing guys
to Dallas you know what I mean or
someone in Jacksonville going right to
the Giants I get that but being able to
hold someone's rights for seven years is
too much and if I were that if I was the
NFLPA I would want to limit franchise
tagging as much as you can and also
lowering the amount of years on a rookie
contract it's not fair
the fact that the Raiders still have not
signed Josh Jacobs they're running back
and the reason is because they're trying
to defer signing bonus payments and this
is something happened last year or two
year a few years ago with Joey Bosa
where NFL's teams are still trying to
like suck out every little dollar you
should only get these guys for three
years because then they can hit that
firt that second contract sooner and
then even if you franchise tag them
they're still getting out there a year
earlier I'm fighting for years just as
much as I'm fighting for percentage of
the overall money being brought in I
just think with the franchise tag the
franchise tag is what lead like the mean
salary of the top five paid players at a
straight position so if that works out
for a receiver one year it's like
sixteen million dollars I think if
you're gonna franchise someone it should
be double the mean salary it should be
punitive it should be because the player
is taking on a risk by accepting the
franchise tag and the team is getting
some additional flexibility in the way
they can negotiate with this player
later all right
I think if the mean salary of the top
five players in the position is 16 you
should have to pay that player 32
million dollars for that one year so
it's a guarantee that you keep your guy
for a year I have an extra year as a
negotiation window but it should be
really punitive to your salary cap
that's we only ever approach that number
after they've been franchise tag twice
that's why Kirk Cousins was released
because the rat washington was gonna
have to pay him like forty to fifty
million dollars because every year they
do add more but I do kind of like making
it even harsher in that first it should
have it should be a real question along
the front office is like do we really
want to franchise right this guy because
it's gonna cost us me Leon yeah cuz
right now Jadeveon Clowney and Grady
Jarrett are sitting here going I gotta
play the whole year on a franchise tag
hope I don't get hurt right and it's
more like man if clowny and Grady
Jarrett were allowed to at the market
for agency would have been a lot of fun
that's what I'm saying ah so David and I
we are actually headed to Lake Tahoe on
Wednesday which is gonna be a blast
it's gonna be like a celebrity golf
tournament and the hope is we're gonna
get a lot of cool interviews for this
podcast so we're doing that and then I
got to go to Vegas for some Bleacher
Report's stuff but misty Ingmar and I
are about to hit the road for a lot of
different stuff that new show on YouTube
that I know some of you saw in like the
Wall Street Journal I don't want to give
out too much details right now but we're
ditching the playbook and we're hitting
the road and we're gonna make some
really cool stuff with a bunch of
different athletes and as I have more
information I'll get it to you guys
because it this version of the show is
gonna be stuff that we've talked about
on here taken to a really really fun
level so I think it'll be really good so
let's hit that music for mr. David
Ingeborg
I am Adam Lefko thank you to warren
sharp thank you to you guys we're saying
goodbye just if you see a mom with a
stroller in front of a set of stairs
help her carry it up or down the stairs
if she looks like she needs some help
it's a great piece of advice yeah I'm
gonna say go up go up to somebody and
say how are you doing and then listen to
what they have to say great advice and
then then you can spit oh I got to go
but give that person like 20 seconds of
listening give them the space yes
good [ __ ] holla holla holla appreciate
you guys lef koe me an out talk to you
guys soon
[Music]